SUNIL JAMES: Good morning,
everybody.
My name's Sunil James, and I'm
a product manager with Google
Cloud Platform.
With me is John Cormie,
a senior
engineer also on the team.
And today, we're going to be
introducing to you a brand new
feature in Google Compute Engine
that delivers to you
greater network control
than ever before.
So let's get to it.
So I know this is supposed to
be an advanced session.
But I thought it wise to take
just a few minutes to walk you
through some of the
basics of what GCE
networking has to offer.
So first, Google Computer Engine
allows you to create a
private layer three network
within the context of the
broader Google Cloud
that can cut across
multiple GCE regions.
By default, a GCE region is
sized to a /16 insider
notation, which is about 65,000
RFC 1918 IP addresses.
Second, GCE gives you the
ability to attach a static,
public IP address to any given
instance within your network.
These IPs are portable across
zones within a region.
Third, as part of the underlying
network fabric, GCE
delivers to you industrial grade
firewall technology that
enables you to define which
incoming connections are
accepted by which instances.
And by the way, this fabric is
the same exact fabric, same
global, high bandwidth, low
latency backbone network
that's used by all the other
Google created Google products
that you probably use
every single day.
So we launched GCE last year.
And we've spent a lot of time
talking to developers, talking
to customers, trying to
understand what they want to
do, what they want to achieve.
And from the networking
standpoint, it's a
long list of things.
And we're going to be working
very hard to deliver month
over month over the coming
months a great set of
networking capabilities.
But to start off with for today,
I want to talk about
some of the nearer term or
most pressing issues that
customers have said they'd like
to be able to tackle.
First, we've had customers say
to us, I'd really like to be
able to create and enable
hybrid cloud.
I'd like to be able to connect
my existing data centers with
my private GCE networks so
that I can actually move
workloads between two without
necessarily breaking the
security barrier that exist
with my existing WAN.
Another use case has been, I'd
really like to be able to have
the ability to have all my
private VMs share just one,
static IP address.
Just give me a NAT
opportunity.
Or give me a NAT instance,
for example.
And then third, we've had
customers who say, I want to
be able to instrument proxies
within the context of my
networks so that I can do
things like enforce AUP
policies and things
of that sort.
So we've digested all
of this feedback.
And we're really proud and
really excited to give you
guys a chance to take a look at
the set of advanced routing
capabilities that GCE is
bringing to market today.
So the work that we've done
with the advanced routing
extends upon a set of networking
technologies that
have been in GCE
since day one.
The diagram on this slide
describe some of the basic
components within the GCE
network, starting with that
red object, which is a massively
scalable, virtual
router that sits at the core of
every single GCE network.
Every single VM in your network
is directly connected
to this router.
So when a VM needs to send a
packet, the router takes a
look at the VMs [INAUDIBLE] a
routing table, as indicated by
those tan boxes, and then
determines what the
next hop should be.
Starting today, we're beginning
to give you greater
ability to actually configure
this router than ever before.
And that's what GCE advanced
routing's all about.
As you'll see in the rest of
this presentation, we've
extended the routing
capabilities so that you can
do many of the things that
I was talking about
beforehand and more.
But a few procedural items just
make sure we're all on
the same page.
So first, each cloud project you
create includes one routes
collection that contains all the
routes applicable to the
GCE network's provision as
part of that project.
Second, each GCE network has two
default routes, one that
automatically routes traffic to
the internet, and one that
routes VM to VM traffic within
your network itself.
So let's talk about some of the
components of what is in
GCE advanced routing.
First off, we have
route names.
So route name is the user
friendly name of a route.
In this case, we named the route
vpn-route to indicate a
route for VPN traffic.
Second, we have network.
Network is the name of the GCE
network to which the route is
applicable to.
Third, we have destination
range.
This is the set of IP addresses
to which the route's
going to apply.
Fourth, we have instance tags.
So instance tags tell the
virtual router which VMs a
route needs to apply to.
So if a route has no tags, for
example, it then applies to
all the VMs within the
network itself.
Next hop, it directs the
router to send matching
traffic to a designated
VM or a gateway.
Next hop VMs can be
identified both by
name and by IP address.
And then lastly, priority value,
which is used to help
break ties.
Rather, I'm sorry, priority
value, which is used to help
break ties when there are more
than one most specific
matching route.
So lower priority value
actually equals higher
priority, like when you're
prioritizing
bugs, if you will.
So when a packet leaves a VM,
the virtual router employees
the following logic
to decide how to
route the packet itself.
First, GCE only keeps the most
specific routes that match a
packet's destination.
Next, it looks at the remaining
routes, and then
only keeps those with the lowest
priority value, which
as we mentioned earlier indicate
highest priority.
And then lastly, if there are
any remaining ties, the
virtual router then computes a
hash based on the fields you
see in the slide to select
the next hop.
If the next hop is found, the
virtual router then forwards
the packet along.
If it's not, the virtual
router's going to drop that
packet and reply back with an
ICP destination or network
unreachable error.
And one last thing I'd like to
mention to you is that before
you can employee a VM as a
forwarding device, you must
upon creating that VM set the
can_ip_forward flag as shown
in the example GCE [INAUDIBLE]
command that's
on the screen here.
The reason for this is because
GCE's default security posture
prevents VMs from spoofing
the source IP address
of egressing packets.
As such, enabling this flag
actually allows the VM to
forward packets with a source IP
address other than its own,
which is exactly the
functionality we need
here in this case.
Now, I know that these
capabilities are really powerful.
But I know that they're also
sometimes really complex.
And so personally, I find
it helpful to visualize
this kind of stuff.
So maybe John, you can walk us
through some examples to
describe what we've
been having here.
JOHN CARMIE: Yeah.
Thanks, Sunil.
Thank you.
All right, so for each one of
those things that Sunil just
told you about, we're going to
illustrate it with an example.
The first thing I want to show
you an example of is
constructing the
routing table.
All right, so here on the white
board, I've drawn a
network in Compute Engine.
And we have the project's route
collection of to the
right hand side there.
The components are the route
name, one through three, the
tags, which are represented as
little tag shaped colors, and
the network, which is
the third column.
So the routing table for an
instance, remember, is a
subset of this project's
route collection.
And the system constructs it
by selecting rows from that
table where the network matches
and the tags match.
You need to know that if there
are no tags on a route, it
means it matches any VM.
So let's look at one example,
that top VM there, number one.
It gets route one because route
one has no tags, and so
it matches any VM.
It gets route three because
it shares the
green tag in common.
It does not get route two
because it doesn't share any
tag in common.
If you're familiar with Compute
Engine firewalls, this
is all very similar.
All right, now that we have
a routing table, imagine a
packet leaves the VM.
And the system's got to pick
the next hop for it.
It's going to consult this
routing table and walk through
that route selection recipe that
Sunil just told us about.
There are three steps.
And I'm going to illustrate two
of those with examples.
The first thing the system does,
recall, is it's going to
pick the most specific routes,
the most specific matching
routes from the instances
table.
So for again, the visual
thinkers out there, this is
how I think about most
specific matches.
In this example, we have
a packet destined for
10.120.1.2.
It's that star at the
bottom there.
And the routing table is
the four routes in
the upper right corner.
First, I want to tell you a
little bit about the notation
if it's not familiar.
For example, 10.120.0.0/16.
That's how we denote
an IP prefix.
The thing on the left-hand
side of the
slash is the IP prefix.
And the thing on the right hand
side tells you how many
bits of that address
are significant.
So 10.120.0.0/16 means anything
that starts with 10.120.
Now, I like to think of the IP
address space as a giant
binary tree.
And the root of that tree
is the top of that
black triangle there.
The leaves, all 2 to the 32 of
them, are the IP addresses
themselves.
And they run along the bottom.
And the interior nodes
are IP prefixes.
And that's where we can hang
routes off in our table.
So there's four routes
in this example.
And you can see visually that
for this destination, three of
them match-- black, red, and
blue-- because their
destination lies within the
sub-trees of those routes.
It does not much green because
it doesn't lie within the
green subtree.
OK, so we have three matches.
But we only care about
the most specific.
Now again, you can see visually
that the most
specific routes are the
smallest subtrees.
And so we actually have a
tie for most specific
between red and blue.
Even though black matches,
it's less specific
than red and blue.
And so it doesn't apply.
All right, so now we have the
most specific matches.
The next step of the route
selection recipe is the
priority selection.
That's pretty straightforward.
We discard routes of lower
priority, so I'm not going to
illustrate that.
We'll jump to the third step,
which is flow hashing.
So there can only
be one next hop.
And so if you have ties left
that are equally specific and
equal priority, we have to
pick one of them somehow.
And so as Sunil said earlier,
the system computes a hash of
the destination packet.
And you can see this at the
bottom of the slide.
H is the hash function.
And it operates on all the parts
of that packet leaving
the VM-- source IP, the source
port if there is one, the
destination IP, the destination
port if there is
one, and the protocol.
And so out of the hash function,
we get a number.
And we use that number to index
into any remaining ties.
And whichever route that picks,
that's where the packet
goes as the next hop.
OK, so now you understand
the algorithm and the
mechanics of this.
But like, why?
Why do we do this?
What is the hash good for?
Well, the answer is scale.
And I'm going to illustrate
it with this example.
So in this example network,
the administrator has
configured it so that all
traffic going to the internet
needs to pass through a gateway
VM, say for some
security or policy reason.
Now, this works fine for a
while, but the number of VMs
in his or her network is
growing over time.
And so eventually, we get to a
point where no one gateway can
handle the number of
packets that are
flowing to the internet.
And so yeah, you can buy a
bigger VM for the gateway to
have more power to process
those packets.
But eventually, you're buying
our biggest VM, and you can't
scale up anymore.
You have to scale out.
And so as you can see in this
picture, we've scaled out by
adding a second gateway.
But the second gateway only
helps you if you can
distribute load across
gateways.
And so that's where this
hash function comes in.
What the hash function does
is assigns flows to
next hops at random.
And so as the number of flows
grows large, you are
distributing your load more or
less evenly across gateways.
Not perfectly evenly, because
everyone is kind of
a random coin flip.
But as the number of flows
gets large, it's
more or less even.
And so that's load balancing
of flows leaving the VMs.
Now, note that we don't assign
packets to gateways randomly.
We assign flows randomly.
And so that's important because
for protocols like
TCP, if you're processing
packets in parallel, they can
get out of order.
And that slows you down.
All right, so we've done
a lot of talking
about advanced routing.
I'm really excited to be
able to show it to you
today in our demo.
What we're going to do is build
a site to site VPN using
Compute Engine, open source
software, and
the new routing feature.
But you know, we're engineers.
We're not cowboys or cowgirls.
We have to design our
network first.
So first thing we're going to
do is jump on the whiteboard
and sketch out a
network design.
And you know, it's going to take
a few iterations to get
something workable.
And I hope those iterations will
motivate why routes are
important and a good
and useful thing.
OK, after we have the design,
we're going to use the gcutil
command line tool to show you
the resources in GCE that
we've already created to model
this network design.
Finally, we're going to SSH into
VMs, send some packets,
and see them moving through our
network in the way we've
configured using the trace
route tool and
the TCP dump tool.
OK, so first the design phase.
Here's an existing,
hypothetical, on premises,
back office application that we
want to move to the cloud.
There's a couple parts.
There's the front end here,
those office FE machines.
Those are the database
clients.
And there's the back end,
the database itself.
All these parts live
on a private
RFC1918 real world network.
What I want you to notice
about this very simple
application is that there's
actually two layers of
security here.
The first layer is the
application layer.
And what I mean by that is those
database clients need to
have a username and password
to log into the database.
And that secret credential is
embedded in them, say it's in
a config file that's maybe
only readable by some
user on that box.
The second layer of
security is the
network layer of security.
None of these pieces
are connected
to the public internet.
And so if you want to access
them, you have to be
physically connected
to that network.
Now, notice these
two layers are
independent and kind of redundant.
They back each other up.
So if know the username and
password to the database, but
you aren't connected to the
network, you're out of luck.
You can't access the data.
And conversely, if you somehow
break into the office building
and connect to the network,
but you don't know the
username and password,
again you're stuck.
So these kind of overlapping
or independent, redundant
security layers, that's
something we're going to try
and preserve as we move
to the cloud.
Now, one constraint.
We're not going to
move the whole
application to the cloud.
We're just going to move
the front ends.
Say, for whatever reason, just
to make it interesting, we'll
keep OfficeDB--
it has to stay in office-net.
All right, so here's our first
shot at doing this.
Let's be totally naive, just
do the simplest thing that
could possibly work.
We'll take those database
clients, spin up VMs for them.
Well, first we have to
create a network.
So we'll create a network,
cloud-net, in Compute Engine.
We'll take our address space,
our RFC1918, it's in the 10.
range.
And we'll split it.
We'll give half the address
space to the cloud, and keep
half in office-net.
We'll spin up some VMs to
represent those database
clients, give them public
IP addresses.
And well, since they need to
talk to OfficeDB, we better
put that on the public
internet, too.
And so now, great, everyone
can talk to each other.
And we're done.
Well, no.
This is a nonstarter for me from
a security perspective
because we've thrown away our
network layer of security.
Now, anyone at any coffee shop
Wi-Fi connection can access
our resources over
the internet.
And so we've thrown away that
network layer of security.
All right, so let's try again
and sprinkle some VPN magic on
this design and see
if that helps us.
We'll take OfficeDB off the
public internet, put it back
in office-net.
That was a bad idea.
Let's not do that.
Put it back in office-net
behind the firewall.
And we'll keep those front end
VMs on the public network.
And we'll spin up VPN tunnels
that connect them to the
router of office-net.
Say IPsec is your
VPN connection.
By the way, this is possible
without advanced routing.
You could have done
this a week ago
before we launched it.
But I see three problems with
this design that I want to
share with you.
First problem I see is that if
you have n of those front end
VMs, n of those database
clients, you need n tunnels.
This is more of a remote
access than a
site to site VPN.
And so for each of those
tunnels, that's an entry in
that router's config file.
And as that config file grows
larger with all those tunnels,
your network administrator's
starting
to get sad and grumpy.
So that's a problem.
n tunnels is a lot to manage.
Oh, and moreover, every time you
want to scale up or down
those VMs in the cloud, which
is touted as one of the
benefits, you have to change
that config file to add or
remove tunnels.
That's kind of a management
pain.
That's the first
problem I see.
The second problem I see
is that those VMs
have to have special--
their operating system, their
guest OS-- needs to be
specially configured
to use the VPN.
Their local routing table needs
to know which packets go
over the VPN and which
packets don't.
And so that's a pain to manage
because you have a bunch of
configurations spread out
over all these VMs.
Oh, and you need root access to
set up those routing tables
because it's a privilege
operation.
So another management pain
multiplied by n.
The final problem I see with
this design is that, well, how
do those cloud FEVMs, those
database clients, actually
authenticate when they connect
to the router?
How does the router know
that they're allowed to
connect to the VPN?
Look, there must be some secret
key, or credential, or
something also embedded on
those clouds FE VMs that
allows them access
to that network.
And wow, that credential is
stored in the exact same place
as the application
layer credential.
And so even though it seems like
we have a network layer
of security and an application
layer of security, they're not
really that independent because
the secrets are stored
in the exact same place.
So here's our final design that
I want to propose to you
guys today.
What we're going to do is take
the VPN logic and move it out
of those client VMs and into
the network and into a new,
designated, router VM that
you can see there
cloud-vpn-gateway on the left.
And so he's going to terminate
the tunnel that
goes to office router.
And we're going to use GCE
routes to direct traffic
destined for the VPN to that
designated VPN gateway VM.
Now, this addresses those three
problems I claim from
the last slide.
First of all, now a number of
VPN tunnels scales with the
number of packets per second
that you want to send over it,
not the number of users.
So you can probably get away
with fewer tunnels.
The second problem it addresses
is that now those
client VMs can be
totally stock.
They don't know anything
about the VPN.
They can just dump packets on
the network, and the network
will figure out where they're
going based on
the destination address.
The third problem this addresses
is that now the
secrets that allow you to
authenticate and construct
that VPN tunnel live in a
different place than the
application layer secrets.
And so you can also have some
policy to back this up and
make it even more independent.
So say at Office Co, maybe
there's one group of
developers that work
on the application.
And they have access to the
username and password.
And they can log into the cloud
FE VM and the database.
And maybe there's a separate
group of people, the network
administrators, that can
log into routers.
And now, cloud VPN gateway
is one of those routers.
And so maybe no one individual
has access to both secrets.
So this is what I'm going
to demo today.
And we'll come back to this
picture as we go.
Great.
So during rehearsal, one of our
reviewers suggested that,
hey, to really model office-net,
you should drag a
rack full of gear up on stage,
servers and routers and
everything, and that'll be the
physical network that you're
going to connect to the cloud.
That's great showmanship, but
I took the easy way out.
And instead of doing that, we're
going to create just
separate networks in GCE
that's going to model
office-net.
So we have two networks in
GCE, cloud-net, which
represents the expansion of
office-net, which is our
second network.
And this is actually realistic
because two networks in GCE
are totally--
if they're separate networks,
they have no connectivity by
default between them.
So it's kind of the
same thing.
What I want you to note about
this slide or this output of
gcutil is that the two address
spaces of the two networks are
non-overlapping.
And so you can tell the
destination network for a
packet just by looking
at those first two
bytes of the address.
OK, I've also created some
VMs to model this design.
And here they are.
We have cloud FE VM,
which remember is
this guy in the picture.
We have 2 VPN gateways, cloud
VPN gateway and office VPN
gateway, that model this
guy and this guy.
And finally, we have OfficeDB,
which is another VM running
over here in office-net.
Two things you can't see here--
unfortunately gcutil
doesn't print them--
are the tags.
So I've tagged both of these.
I've tagged cloud FE FM and
OfficeDB with the VPN tag.
And that's what we're going to
use to join routes and allow
them to use the VPN.
And the second thing I've done
is I've given-- remember the
can_ip_forward flag?
I've set that on cloud
VPN gateway
and office VPN gateway.
And that allows them to do their
job and forward packets.
OK, so here's what's
new, list routes.
This is the routes collection
for the project.
And the defaults aren't
that interesting.
I haven't changed those.
What I want you to notice is
these two routes here that
make the VPN go, gateway to
office, and gateway to cloud.
Excuse me.
So what this rule says is that
if you're a VM on cloud-net
and you have the VPN tag, shows
you permission to access
the VPN, and you send the packet
that falls in this
destination range, don't
handle it normally.
Instead, forward it to this
special, designated VM for
processing, OK?
And this address space is the
address space of the peer
network on the other
side of the tunnel.
So note the symmetry here.
This gateway to cloud is
exactly the same in the
opposite direction.
If you're a VM on office-net and
you have the VPN tag and
you're sending a packet to
cloud-net, then send it to
this special VM for
processing.
OK, so those are the resources
I've created to model this
network design.
Let's jump on to cloud FE VM.
I'm sorry.
Let's jump on to the
VPN gateway.
Remember, that's this
guy right here.
And what I want to show you is
that I've already installed
and configured the strongSwan
one, VPN software.
It's just sudo apt-get
install strongSwan.
And I've already set it up
so that it's running.
And the tunnel's established.
And you can see that we've
joined these two halves of the
address space.
OK, so the VPN's
up and running.
We're going to do a quick
connectivity check here.
I've now logged into
cloud FE VM.
That's this guy.
This is our database client.
What we're going to do is send
a ping request to OfficeDB to
check connectivity.
Now remember that normally, by
default, two GCE networks have
no connectivity at all.
And so the fact that we get
a response shows you that
something interesting and new
and special is happening.
The two networks have
connectivity to each other.
But hey, how do we know that
it's really happening in the
way that I'm claiming?
Well, let's use the trace route
tool to find the path
that that packet's taking.
And as you can see, it's exactly
what we expect from
the whiteboard diagram.
The first hop is cloud
VPN gateway.
So remember, the ping is
going here, first top.
Second hop is the office
VPN gateway.
And third hop is OfficeDB.
They're there.
OK, that's pretty cool.
Let's jump on to OfficeDB and
see what it looks like from
the server's perspective.
OK, so I'm going to
start a TCP dump.
TCP dump's a tool that captures
packets the match a
certain expression in
a Unix machine and
print it to the screen.
So I'm going to start that up.
And while that's running, I'm
going to send that same
packet, that same
ping request.
And so here here's what that
network flow looks like from
the server's perspective.
What I think is cool about this
dump is that the source
address and the destination
address are
just 10 space, right?
You don't see the addresses
of the VPN endpoints.
And this is why people
like VPN.
This is why people want VPN,
because we took an existing
application on one network and
we put it on two networks.
And the application didn't
have to be rewritten or
changed in any way because
the packets
looked exactly the same.
And if you've designed your VPN
right, you get some of the
security benefits, too, of being
on a private network,
like confidentiality
and authenticity.
So that's from a server's
perspective.
Now, the final thing that I want
to show you, I think is
the coolest, is a
TCP dump from--
let me just clear this--
from the VPN gateway.
So now, we're going to capture
packets on this guy.
I'm going to send
that same ping.
And we're going to see how
this guy handles it.
OK, so wow.
There's a lot going on here.
I'm going to quickly step
through it for you.
Oops.
Very unlucky.
I captured a packet
I didn't want to.
Try again.
All right, so this very
first packet is
what's coolest to me.
What's cool is that the
destination address is on a
completely different network
than this VM.
So if this is the first time
you've see something like
this, you might ask, what is
this packet doing on my
network interface?
It's destined for someone
else, right?
Well, that's the routes
collection working.
We created a route that said,
this packet destined for this
other guy should go to this
cloud VPN gateway VM instead.
And it is kind of weird to
have packets destined for
someone else show up on your
network interface.
But that's the definition of
being a router, right?
People dump things
on your doorstep.
And it's your job to figure out
what to do with them next.
OK, well, what does this
VM do with it next?
You can see the answer to that
in the very next packet.
What it does is it encrypts
that packet.
You can see that.
Now it's using the
IPsec protocol.
It encapsulates it.
So the source address has
changed to be its own.
And the destination address has
changed to be the public
IP of the other end
of the VPN tunnel.
And so that's the encapsulation
part.
It's like an envelope, taking
that original packet and
putting it in a new,
larger packet.
You can see it's 132 bytes
instead of 64.
And sending it to a
new destination
OK, the next time we hear
from this flow is a few
milliseconds later.
And it's actually the ICMP
reply coming back.
It's coming back from the IP
address at the other end of
the tunnel.
It's also encrypted.
It's also encapsulated.
So Linux has built
in IPsec support.
I've configured it to decrypt,
decapsulate that packet, and
dump it back on its own local
networking stack.
And so this next entry shows
you that ICMP replied,
emerging from the tunnel
on this Linux machine.
Well, I've configured the guest
OS, this Linux operating
system, to be also-- to
think it's a router.
And so it has its own IP
forward flags set.
And so Linux knows that
it has access to
this destination network.
And so it sends it out for GCE
to deliver to the destination,
which is actually the
original pinger.
This last packet is super cool,
too, because look at
this source address.
This source address is a VM on
a totally different network.
It's on office-net.
And so this is why the
can_ip_forward flag is
important because this gateway
is actually sending a packet
where the source address
is not its own.
It's like it's spoofing,
right?
But it's not for evil.
It's for good.
It's to make this transparent
VPN work.
All right, that's everything
I wanted to
show you in the demo.
I hope you guys think this
is as cool as I do.
I'm going to send it back
to Sunil to summarize
and wrap this up.
SUNIL JAMES: Great.
Thank you, John.
So as you just said, we just
demonstrated to you guys how
to move a back office
application to the cloud while
retaining some of the security
properties of it being a
private physical network.
Just to recap, we took the Linux
built-in IPsec stack
plus some open source VPN
software and GCE's advanced
routing capability to connect
together these two networks
and layer three so that by
specifying GCE route, that
directed traffic to the
designated gateway VM.
Then, we set the can_ip_forward
flag on that VM
acting as the VPN gateway to
send forward packets and
receive packets for
forwarding.
And then finally, we used trace
route and TCP dump to
show you guys packets flowing
from the origin VM through the
VPN gateway.
That was using routes.
And then, through the VPN
tunnel across the public
internet, all the while
preserving the packet source
and destination IP addresses.
So now, as you saw, this
was just a demo.
And it's not meant to be a
comprehensive how to guide to
roll your own VPN,
necessarily.
So before you go off and take
this demonstration as gospel,
I ask you to go talk to security
experts at your
organization, figure out
what makes the most
sense for your business.
So with that, I'm going to
take some questions.
If you're thinking about
leaving, I'd suggest sticking
around for after the questions
because there's one more thing
that I'm going to show you after
we're done with that.
So let me open it up
for questions.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Hi, I was
just wondering
if it's easily possible.
You were showing an example
where you have two gateways
handling traffic between the
cloud environment and the
internet, for example.
Is it easily possible for one of
these gateways to, say, I'm
serving more traffic
than I can handle.
I'll spin up another instance
of myself somewhere else.
And then, I either need to
reconfigure the routing tables
on the router to make that
gateway available, or I need
to have them pre-configured to
just see that new upcoming
instance and use it?
JOHN CARMIE: So that's
definitely possible.
You would have to write the
code that does that.
So the API to spin up a new
instance, it's an API.
It can do that.
And the API to control the
routing table, it can also
automate that.
So yeah, that's a great idea.
AUDIENCE: So that could
be changed on the fly.
JOHN CARMIE: Say again?
AUDIENCE: So the routing table
can be updated on the fly
without much latency?
JOHN CARMIE: Yes, yes.
And so when you create a new
route, what happens is it's
kind of an async operation.
You get back an operation
object.
And then, you can pull that and
see when it's complete.
And so once it's complete, that
means that everyone in
the network has got
that new route.
And it's kind of in service
and ready to go.
AUDIENCE: And that runs on the
order of milliseconds, or does
that take a while?
JOHN CARMIE: I think it takes
a few seconds right now.
That's anecdotally.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: In a similar interest,
so you had your
dummy load balancing
example, which was
this hash based, simple.
Is there a lot of ability in
there to actually have it
automated and intelligent enough
to actually keep track
of the amount of flows that are
remaining constant servers
and do on automatic load
balancing that is actually
intelligent as the amount of
traffic changes on the
different servers?
JOHN CARMIE: Yes, so
you could do that.
But again, you would
have to write
that automation yourself.
So you could have counters on
your gateway VMs, monitoring
CPU, monitoring how many packets
per second they're
doing, and react to it by
spinning up new instances, and
then adding routes to add them
to the pool of gateways.
AUDIENCE: OK, the servers will
actually have to end up giving
feedback to the gateway.
You can't actually have the
gateway solitarily trying to
figure things out?
JOHN CARMIE: You could.
From inside GCE, you can make
calls to the control API and
add new instances and
create new routes.
So yeah, that's one
possible design.
Another possible would be to
monitor it from the outside
and spin up new resources
as needed.
AUDIENCE: Awesome, thank you.
JOHN CARMIE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I guess along the same lines,
so you said we can do this
flow-based load balancing for
VPN gateways where my gateways
are on a VM.
What happens on the north-south
traffic where I'm
using the public IPs and
going out to the world?
Do I have that--
will the Google infrastructure
essentially take care of
spreading my flows or my load
across multiple gateways going
out to the internet?
And I don't have to worry about
it, or do I have to do
something special myself?
JOHN CARMIE: So the answer is
that the routing table doesn't
know whether it's
a VPN connection
or an internet gateway.
It's just thinking
about packets.
And so the same trick
works in both cases.
Does that answer
your question?
Or maybe I didn't understand.
AUDIENCE: No, I was wondering
that to go out to the
internet, do I need a separate
VM which is my gateway, and--
JOHN CARMIE: No.
Yeah, so this is
just an option.
You don't need to use
a separate VM
to get to the internet.
By default, you get
a route which is--
let me actually go back
and show you.
SUNIL JAMES: So it's
implicit, right?
It's one of the implicit
routes that
exists within our utility.
JOHN CARMIE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, it's
an implicit route.
But will the implicit route,
will whatever that gateway is
going to the internet, does
that actually load balance
across multiple devices if I'm
saturating the physical
whatever device it is?
JOHN CARMIE: Well, OK.
Let me first address
the route point.
So this default route is what
takes you-- you can't see it
because I had to truncate to
make this fit on the screen.
But the next hop is actually an
object which is called the
default internet gateway.
And it's not a real
physical thing.
It's just something
that should be
in your mental model.
It's the thing that gets
you to the internet.
And you don't need to worry
about scaling it.
We worry about that
behind the scenes.
And so it's not one
physical device.
It scales up as needed.
AUDIENCE: As needed, OK.
JOHN CARMIE: And that's
part of the magic.
So you don't need to
worry about that.
If you're running your own
gateways, though, then as a
question over there pointed out,
yes, you do need to worry
about that.
AUDIENCE: So I realize
this demo falls
under just one project.
But given the example you could
run, could I use that to
establish connectivity between
two different projects?
JOHN CARMIE: Yes, yes.
Because from the VPN gateway's
perspective, it's just sending
packets to an IP address
out anywhere
on the public internet.
So it could be an instance
in a different project.
It could be an instance
running in a different
provider's cloud.
It could be an instance
running in
your home data center.
And it doesn't matter.
AUDIENCE: OK.
But in that case, it would
still have to transit
to some public IP.
I couldn't do say two different
projects, they're
all Google Compute projects.
But I want to establish
connectivity without
necessarily hitting outside to
make it faster or better.
JOHN CARMIE: OK, you're asking
whether it physically leaves
the Google infrastructure?
AUDIENCE: Maybe it
doesn't leave.
Maybe you've handled it.
I'm just curious.
SUNIL JAMES: Or another way to
position it is, is there a
short circuit path from
one project to
another to get to networks?
So I think the answer--
I'll take a stab at answering
this question.
There's no short circuit path.
It's still going to egress to
whatever egress point that
exists at the top of the tree
for the traffic that's being
sent out to the internet.
So you do have to have it
communicating on a public IP.
But that doesn't mean that it's
egressing the network.
It's just going up to the
edge of our network, and
then right back down.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
Thank you.
SUNIL JAMES: OK.
So we'll be around to answer a
few more questions afterwards.
But I wanted to just take, with
the two minutes left,
walk you through one more
thing that we're doing.
So as I said before, we are part
of the Cloud Networking
team at Google Cloud Platform.
And so we talked a little bit
earlier about all the things
that we've heard developers
asking for.
This is a great starting
point.
And it's only going to get
richer and better in terms of
the functionality of just
advanced routing.
But there are other things
that customers ask for.
And so I'm really, really,
really excited to talk about
load balancing.
So we're going to be bringing
you load balancing as part of
the native fabric for Google
Compute Engine.
We're not releasing details
about the service yet.
We're building it right now.
If you're interested in learning
more about load
balancing, come up
and find me.
Or go ahead and click
on that goo.gl link.
I'll leave it up for you
guys to write down.
It'll take you to a forum where
you can answer some
questions about what you need
out of the service.
And I'll follow up with
you personally.
We can sit down and talk more
about what you need.
Additionally, GCE has an early
access program whereby you can
get access to all the great, new
upcoming features within
Compute Engine, including load
balancing when it's available.
So that's what we
wanted to say.
So thank you very much.
JOHN CARMIE: Thank you
so much, guys.
[APPLAUSE]